oh here's big news we're going to show
you [ __ ]
so this is that we're very excited like
we today was I was been looking forward
to it we got Aaron black Liu Kang and
Shin up you guys you can try to use it
no cuz he's in practice oh we oh that's
right I forgot we're also going to
discuss how practice mode yes
we're filled with a lot of things today
so we have a nice little training room
that you can use it'll be really nice
good one
this really nice training they're really
really nice they will not speak to each
other so this is an impostor shut up the
one that I use the most and summing over
is basically oh yeah he's got a he's got
a handle the glassware you grab this
amulet does a little slower you flash
with it there's just a bigger blast on
this point actually if I can go and make
the sub-zero you make one mistake Paul
has a low tolerance yeah so has this
triple ground blast which is which it's
on three or four ranges it always does
helpful glass it's more mental like
and you can enhance this move after they
sort of come string and you can sit on
another Universal moves this big which
Wizards are known for shoulder yeah yeah
yeah
there's some of unique thing to practice
is um you can sit like your positions of
the where you're going to reset the game
- it's like I'm going to set it to the
left here real quick and I'm like uh if
you're playing online and like
sub-zero's are are playing against you
in like and the expo sub-zero's are
pressing in the corner and like putting
in actual situations you can actually
use practice mode to figure how to get
out of some of these situations so
you're gonna set the recording and you
can actually record what the other sub 0
which is zero point it's gonna do
against you and you can set whether or
not you're blocking you're not blocking
it so I'm gonna set it to you block and
Doug and I do like what I set up for so
as always do you figure out how what I
can do to stop this right here reversal
I can actually
if I do that I can't go and then you
think you feel like if I'm like I'm
reversers with yeah I'm sort of still in
the corner and I'm shoulder actually
because you can set up low situations of
like a these things are like beating me
matches and you can have final Winston
it's really good like for me when I
first started playing these kind of
games I was super yes I would definitely
find the move that I couldn't quite be
recorded and just try every single thing
to get out of it and like you know you
do that enough then you get into a real
match and you you do it on reaction dojo
yep another cool thing I think we have
it in here where you can actually put on
the different backgrounds and such yeah
yeah we should talk about the training
background yeah
so right now the show your background
doesn't have any of interactive objects
folded well you can set it to load
different ones so you can set it to loco
and it'll quickly load the coab
interactable
inside a train room right so now that
everything is in the cove so if you want
to kind of try you know interactive
specific combos which can exist you can
change these out all through practice
mode they all just click on holograms
can you make a hologram Blanche that
could be the greatest thing don't you
don't spoil me
don't spoil me I'm gonna see if it works
I'm sure this there it is we all know
Blanche said she has a holographic
counterparts she'll live forever
nationwide Blanche 2.0 does she have a
Twitter account if she has a twitter
account I'll probably write it down I
mess it up so she's gonna have a Twitter
account now I bet there's so much
grandmother so burning Blanche is just
right now is getting a whole bunch of
followers right
coal's let's try to go through some of
imposters stuff he does to them
yep what's special to him so a bunch of
shuriken the ability to steal moves from
his opponents so against Sub Zero fine
Landis movie you notice that my my rules
change color on my outfit so that means
that I now have a store does stolen
special move so with this one enters the
exact and if every character you steal
the difference in this arrival so if you
play as a posture Sherlock can be best
for you to learn you can learn different
combo every single character you play
and it's gonna be very matchup depending
where sometimes imposter will be very
good and so matchups in other matches it
might not be as good but for like
sub-zero example you can run you power
went to the most dealer and now I have a
stolen ice ball and then you can
actually tie
cool there are some I think you probably
spent there's no right back as we
contradict it either
combo accurate or diseases kind of like
ice ball again yeah to keep pressure so
there would be a lot of setups these and
then you can use practice mode of course
to figure out something cool alright so
what's the next one
another little bonus flexible you can
quickly switch out variations so right
now we're gonna go to bone shaper and
will switch out sub-zero and breathable
that's just a quick load and then you're
back with the new very agents no player
select not that yeah but I feel like did
this practice mode like every single
game we do we learn a little bit more
about how to make the practice but a
little bit better and this year this is
like by far the best practice what we've
done yeah we competitive players to to
see what it is that they really want to
help them get better in our game and
figure out better setups and whatnot so
we definitely listen to them and with
some of that stuff into yeah like one of
the tough things is fighting games I
think is like bridging that gap between
like you know not quite casual but not
quite like you know tournament level and
this is a great place to kind of go in
and to be able to kinda learn now bone
chipper sugar obviously uses you could
summer long as you can tell them down
you could some a different weapon so
he's got this he also has this up this
little this little dope oh it's a very
good
and then Boneshaker he can slam the
bicycle in the ground which is actually
because yes amulet he actually uses the
little handle the answer that forms in
the other weapon possible yeah maybe we
could see it x-ray oh I don't know if
they're ready for that I don't know if
through it was good right first I'm
gonna show you guys the other
misinformation from the x-ray because
it's awesome
there's some of the little bone k2 traps
your opponent and that actually tracks
the where to your opponents currently
located so it's almost like running away
from your closest back and you thought
he was done
no no I know I've done it's gonna mr.
gragan necromancer versus cryo man sir
crazy now man some answers and you'll
notice he's got these skeleton arms now
to which is visual variation right and
then in necromancer you can summon up
some bones
yep you gotta do
Oh like spoon dirty itself flips away
that means that this lambu which I would
also attracted opponent is it doesn't
block but it's pretty slow to come out
which is like classic nice cool
Blanche watch 2.0 still feel bad for
wool is there anything else really
oh no I don't chamber that's pretty much
it this is gains even bonus special
moves cool well excellent so those are
our three characters for today